even with all the crossover the mcu can
muster there are major characters with
whom thor has never shared the screen
a few were missed connections others
were lost when thor came back to reverse
the thanos snap heard round the universe
these are the six heroes that would make
thor say who the hell are you guys
since peter parker has been in so many
movies it feels odd that he and thor
haven't had a formal introduction they'd
probably get on famously
there's no doubt the impressionable
parker would be very starstruck to me
not just another magical hero like
doctor strange but a god and all that
meanwhile thor would no doubt find the
young man's enthusiasm very charming
hey we haven't officially met
cool unfortunately all the time speeder
has been most relevant to a movie's plot
where specifically those times thor was
not just
unavailable but also usually in a whole
other corner of the galaxy
plus there was that whole period of time
when peter had turned to dust
everyone was on the screen in avengers
end game of course but that doesn't make
for a real introduction
character-wise they're both in a similar
place right now questioning their
identities as heroes having crises of
faith and feeling that they haven't
lived up to their potential
that's a lot of good stock for a
relatable dynamic to come together
this one's a twofer thor hasn't met
either of the wasps either hope or janet
van dyne he's met scott lang and they
seem to get along as well as any random
guy with an electrical engineering
degree can with a near-immortal alien
who can channel lightning and is
currently living through a really deep
depression
but janet and hope were both snapped out
of existence by thanos
and of course thor was nowhere near san
francisco and pym labs at any time
during either ant-man or ant-man on the
wasp
just imagine how great a conversation
between thor traveler of the cosmos and
janet long lost vagabond of the quantum
realm might be
technically there's no proof as to
whether thor has ever met sharon carter
big ensemble movies by their very nature
have to hand wave over a lot of detail
which meant sharon never got a whole lot
of screen time outside of the winter
soldier as a shield agent sharon is
almost definitely used to encountering
the fantastic
and had zero problem dealing with the
likes of steve rogers
so if she ever did meet thor she likely
wouldn't tolerate much attitude from yet
another superhuman blonde dude
captain rogers neighbor including
t'challa king of wakanda may amount to a
technicality as he and thor were both at
the battle of wakanda
t'challa did at least see thor but it
was only at the very end when the latter
made his big splashy arrival with groot
and rocket
considering the fact that very shortly
thereafter the good wakandan king got
himself snapped the two have never
actually been acquainted it's kind of a
shame that they haven't met honestly
they have a lot in common both their
fathers died both have had to fight for
their place in the world and both have
to reconcile the fathers they loved with
terrible legacies about which they were
never previously told
the powers that they were given were at
first taken for granted but then they
had to be re-earned through suffering
t'challa has done well bearing that
emotional burden so thor could really
use a friend like him post-endgame
yondu has been dead a while so obviously
thor would never get an
opportunity to meet him that might not
feel all that relevant but consider how
important the guardians especially
rocket had become to thor
rocket personally dealt with his own
grief when yondu died and that was a
critical step in his journey towards
learning to express empathy
if rocket hadn't experienced that as
part of guardians of the galaxy volume 2
he wouldn't have been nearly as well
equipped to help thor in the way that he
did throughout both infinity war and end
game
i know who you are boy because you're
me
considering all this it's a shame that
thor will never have the opportunity to
meet someone that has provided so much
context to the guardians lives
both bucky and thor fought in the big
battle of end game at the battle of
wakanda and they also attended tony's
funeral
that said they've never exchanged
dialogue and given the friendship
shattering effect bucky had on the
avengers dynamic and thor's absence who
knows what the god of thunder would
think
as it stands there's no on-screen
confirmation that thor even knows who
[ __ ] he is
all bruce banner ever told him in thor
ragnarok was that the avengers fell
apart
not why you know the whole bucky killed
tony's parents thing
until recently he had absolutely no one
to rely on he's a man completely out of
time and place
and is only just starting to readjust
she's gotta be 100 years old right now
so are we pal
meanwhile most of thor's closest friends
are dead and he's feeling a lot of guilt
over his actions leading to a lot of
death he never intended
that's an unexpected common thread
between them and would be an interesting
dynamic to explore should their
narrative threads ever truly cross
wait gamora but thor met her in infinity
war right
she thirsted over his muscles it's like
his muscles are made of katatti metal
fibers
stop massaging his muscles all true
thormet agamora one who no longer exists
in the mcu
the gamora that fans came to know and
love in the mcu died in infinity war
a past version of the green skin
guardian of the galaxy from 2014
one with different motivations and that
of the heroes her future self fought
alongside appeared in endgame
a huge chunk of peter quill's emotional
struggle and end game is coming to the
understanding that the woman who
unknowingly got a second life in a new
timeline isn't
the same woman he fell in love with i
thought i lost you
the 2014 version of gamora who flashes
forward to the year 2023 and end game
didn't experience guardians of the
galaxy and there's no getting that time
back and living it over again
gamora herself knows something is wrong
which is why she ultimately sided with
nebula and betrayed thanos in a new way
this gamora must have the same emotional
journey along a different path and that
story will likely be part of the plot of
guardians of the galaxy 3.
she took off on her own and the rest of
the team is determined to find her and
bring her back into the family where she
belongs
she just doesn't know it yet check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite superheroes are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you